you should see my underwear collection
I've long departed from anything cute
it's full on granny 5000s and I am
standing by my parachute pennies for the
rest of my life I think a baggy panty
there's something sexy about that wait
not bad yesterday just just you know
fully support full support highways full
butt cup yeah full butt coverage okay I
like back I like to buy my panties like
a few sizes too big like just just to be
different just if they might slide down
in your pants
oh there's something cute about that
aesthetic yeah I think you like the the
um aesthetic of diapers right that's
your Vibe I like the boy underwear like
like boxer shorty not boxes if it
doesn't have a cotton gusset I'm out
yeah because then it's like that on my
Tombstone
come out I'm out guess what does have a
cotton gusset Olive skims everything I
know you know this is how I know Kim K
has the Beastie Steves often she
understands the importance of a contest
yeah
um Katie um thank you for being here of
course
um I think you're amazing and your
videos have on many occasion helped me
um not unalive myself
so much so soon but my first question to
you is um little Esther over there has a
Fascination for being in diapers and I I
again too much too soon
put that on your Tombstone
and I want to get to the bottom of why
um she
likes to so you invite the therapist on
just fully break me down and figure
things out yeah I have way more
questions than just the diapers
pretty simple okay I mean can be
any abuse no well I don't actually like
diapers you like to have people wear
them or you like to wear them I like
I definitely am stuck in childhood in a
lot of ways I think that's more what the
situation is when she says diapers right
is that what you mean well no I think
that you what was the threat the last
time that you just wanted to be in die
person not have to go to the restroom
for
a couple days
what was it Esther I feel it's early
early bloodbath episodes
I I look I've evolved a lot in the last
two years
so I would say that I'm not necessarily
looking to be in diapers right now
um
I think uh next question
[Music]
hi sluggies I'm so happy we have such an
amazing show today it's very fun
um you can catch me on my solo podcast
called Annie wood it's on YouTube every
Thursday I live stream chat with
everyone
um on the YouTube so if you go to that
when it premieres at noon Eastern or
nine Pacific you can chat with me and
I'll see it with the first for the first
time with you I also am on the road and
I love meeting you guys more than almost
doing the stand up to be honest I love
it so much uh you can see me in Dania
Beach Florida this weekend February 3rd
and 4th or next weekend
um Washington DC February 24th and 25th
Seattle Washington March 10th and 11th
Tampa Florida March 17th and 18th I'll
then be in Toronto Riley rally Raleigh
sorry Raleigh North Carolina Salt Lake
City and a bunch of other dates go to
annieleterman.com shows come meet me
it's the best
Miami get tickets we're doing stand-up
Esther onice.com I will see you soon
would you like to be taken care of I
love to be taken care of that's what I
was going to say it's almost like the
emotional neglect of childhood like
bleeds into adulthood so you might go
out looking for guys girls people to
like take care of you definitely
um yes I'm realizing that I think I was
emotionally neglected because I always
say that like my parents kept me safe
but like like that was paper yeah like
and I love them and we're super close
now but
um
we why is it like starting out with my
like this trauma but no I think like
another thing that I've realized because
I I host a solo podcast and my like
ethos for that is it's for people who
spent the best years of their lives
alone in their room and like that's me
like I feel like and that's why I'm a
creative person is because
so much of my life I was just like by
myself in my room with my Lion King
figurines and like my stuffed animals
and then it became my Britney Spears
posters and the Muse and my CDs so I
don't know I don't know that I view it
as a bad thing because it's like yes I
the other thing though is like then I
see how adults interact with children
and I'm like whoa this is so different
like oh than the way you were raised
yeah it's like they're included in
conversations and like also
the first time I went out to dinner with
my fiance and his parents
he's like a funny guy and he was just
kind of just being himself and his
parents kept laughing at the things he
said and I will never forget the way I
felt I was like I didn't know it was
physically possible for parents to find
their child funny that was like a for I
was like that's not like literally
physically impossible because you're
just their kid oh that you would think
that you were so much less yes was it
kind of like the the like be seen not
heard type of generation or thing or it
wasn't like that because I definitely am
not shy or like I don't hide but it was
more just like exist over there and do
whatever you want yeah just don't bother
us yeah so you didn't like it to
participate with your parents not really
another thing while we're here
is these are just like the okay another
thing is I saw a commercial ones for
family game night it was like a Hasbro
commercial and I was like
what there's a thing called family game
night and I was like I felt so
much fomo I was really upset are you an
only child I'm a half only child I have
a half older so that doesn't really
count I didn't like grow up together no
I'm just saying like you didn't have a
sibling that like you she was there but
seven years older and wanted nothing to
do with me wouldn't let me in a room
couldn't go in her bed because I would
get my dead skin cells on it I have been
very is she like a germaphobe no
and then even my sister I'll see her
kiss her children and I'm like you allow
their germs I guess like
I asked her let me hold you hence why
she wants to be taken care of yeah you
know what I will change your nappies all
day long that is a vowel thank you
that's why I'm so drawn to you because I
do think you have like your mother
caregiver hence the dog rescue yeah look
um
any time of the day yeah any time of the
day you need your nappies change I'm
there thank you that is a friendship Val
thank you wow yeah I feel very
vulnerable right now but I also like it
of course and then you get a little
attention too yeah yeah people act like
attention is a bad thing but we all need
it it's not bad yeah it's just you
didn't get enough at all as a kid so you
probably need more now as an adult so
now I'm sick
now I'm unwell and I host this podcast
you're not I'm well thank you you're
just doing your best with what you got
yeah that's what we all do I think I'm
on the extreme end of that where it's
like helicopter tiger mom parent just
like I didn't have any freedoms to do
anything I couldn't take a nap like
everything was dictated where it was
just always in my [__] the way what I
ate for breakfast everything down to
like the last morsel like everything was
just so controlled but then still very
emotionally neglected so it's like same
same kind of you know just different
versions like more like physical neglect
and then people don't realize how
abusive or toxic helicopter parenting
can be too because people are like swing
from extreme and I'm like should be in
the middle like kids need Independence
otherwise then we try to control things
on our own eating disorder self-injury
you know things like that because you
don't feel like you have any control
whereas Esther is like nobody cares I
just do whatever yeah and it feels
unsafe also I think also part of it was
my mom is Finnish
and I just that culture like they're
quiet and they're just kind of like so I
feel like I was able to just do anything
and my other was just my mom was just
like okay well here's your cereal that
you asked for and I don't know it's
whatever but your thing of like someone
giving you these rules to follow and
live by I'm almost like oh my God I
would have loved that
structure and discipline even though I
don't think that's true but there's like
a voice inside of me that's like oh I
want that in fact when
the show Alone Together when it got
picked up someone was like What if the
network asked you to lose weight or like
control your body and I remember my
first interaction was like I would love
a corporation to tell me what to do with
it
I was like I would structure so valued
if someone gave me a specific assignment
like that I that would feel seen yes and
I would feel useful in love overseen as
a thing too I was just being fed until I
was 13. I was not allowed to hold my own
utensils that's crazy it's true it is
true you call my mom because she had to
ration out our food because I was the
prized goat in the family I was part of
the swim team since I was like a really
really young kid and I brought in money
so my sister and I well more so me but I
was not allowed to hold my own utensils
because I was not she didn't trust me to
finish the food on my plate which was
usually a mound of pork chop and then
eggs and then rice and then six tomatoes
and then a big glass of milk and I'm
like my 10 year old body cannot consume
all of this and if I would vomit it out
another plate on the table what yeah she
would control the calories she was also
a competitive bodybuilder so like that
yeah so are you sure about the
corporation I know that what you're
explaining is really serious like that
is very severe yeah well Katie knows she
knows a lot about my my trauma because
we've talked about it
um I didn't realize that though I mean
it eating disorder stuff makes sense
then
yeah I have um problem I yeah the eating
disorder in my early 20s was mostly just
trying to
um
um I I just was kind of rendered useless
right I didn't know how to do anything
for myself or even given the opportunity
to try because kids need to try like we
need to try to do things on our own and
fail or not we have to learn right
that's like growth that's how you become
a human an adult right and the
overwhelming feeling that I got most of
my childhood was I cannot wait to have
autonomy so I can take a nap all I
wanted was to take a nap like to just be
like oh I want to fall asleep whenever I
want to fall asleep wake up whenever I
want to wake up and that was the dream
for me as a child wow so how come you
couldn't it wouldn't let you nap because
you argued with like working harder
because you're probably practicing all
the time this is what I wanted to ask
you is there this trauma just like
if it's something where a childish is
overworked like I feel like I don't want
to do like I I my bandwidth is very low
as an adult like I can do one thing a
day and then I'm exhausted hmm I mean
there's a lot of reasons first of all
you've gone to the doctor recently
because vitamin D if that's low yeah so
I've checked all of that I'm kind of
slightly maybe slightly anemic uh energy
also right um thyroid levels are good
everything else is good and I just feel
like
do you ever just feel like okay one
thing that's enough like that was my big
productive thing and then I'm done
I do I know what you mean but
when I think back to myself feeling that
way it's because something was wrong and
it's like
whether it's like for me it's usually
like physical energy the way I'm eating
and or like you also recently went
through a big breakup I feel like that
could be having profound effects on your
life in ways that you maybe don't even
have a clue right I have Clues okay
big Clues yeah yeah their energy sucks
especially when we put ourselves out
there whether that's online or in
performance or whatever because then
what what I find even personally being
online for like 10 years is like the
amount of feedback you receive from
people that you don't care about right I
don't know them they don't know me
but you know it's not normal for us to
receive that much what happens to people
like okay what happens to me and Esther
and Annie to receive like a constant
barrage of that kind of feedback it's
unsolicited some of it we appreciate of
course because we this is the bed we
made and we understand that you know it
comes with a territory that people are
going to remark on your character who
they think you are blah blah blah but
what happens is are like are there
studies done to kind of
um figure out in the long run what
happens to this new wave of
of us I even want to interrupt you and
say that it's not Esther Annie kalila
it's every single everybody yeah
including Katie yes everyone who makes a
tick tock every tick tocker I follow and
eventually on my for you page there's a
video of them being like I'm dealing
everyone hates me like yeah everyone in
today I follow a farmer because I love
animals and Mommy farmer my favorite on
Tick Tock and she wakes them up every
morning and feeds them and she was
crying once on Tick Tock because she was
receiving so much hate and I was like
who the [__] hates mommy Farmers
but everybody gets it like it and I I
don't know I mean there is current
research about the effects of social
media on us as a whole but I don't think
it's from the perspective of us people
who put it out there I think it's from
the perspective of kids growing up with
it right does that make sense yeah
because I mean there is there is even a
huge difference between some like a
musician and an actor because the
feedback is going to be about their
craft not who they they are not their
character but when we podcast and we
share a little bit about our life the
people we love the animals any
everything about it it feels very
personal and it there is like a
parasocial nature about podcasting where
people feel not only entitled to kind of
like owning a piece of you but they your
vo my voice is in their ear has been in
their ear for the past 10 years so there
is
kind of this weird like possessive
nature about the type of
um fan that they are or feeling like
they they know you more than they do
right I mean like I think people do
think because if they've been listening
to you for 10 years they feel like they
know more about you than they probably
do because of that like
that parasocial it's almost I don't know
how to explain it it's almost like
because you share a little they can
extrapolate and then they think they
have the full story or they think they
really know about your relationship but
nobody really knows except for you and
the person in the relationship like even
when my best friends go through divorces
or breakups I don't really know what it
was like for them right like and I'm
with them you know like supporting but
I'm not in the relationship right and
also like I can sit here and speculate
what's going on between Britney Spears
and Madonna and like I have all my ideas
but even just through knowing how little
people really know about our truth it's
like I don't know anything about Britney
Spears and adults but I think I do and I
won't stop thinking that I do but I
don't are you but you're not trolling
either no that's different totally but
I'm I always lately I really try so
weird but I try to relate to the trolls
I try to put myself in their shoes
because I'm I'm always I'm trying to
figure it out and it has helped me
because I put myself in in the shoes of
like what would make me comment this on
someone's video and it's like this would
that would be sad I it would be really
sad if I was doing that and I can
picture the place in my life and that
has helped me a little bit well yeah it
Denver comes out of like love or Joy or
excitement for life oh troll comment
comes out of like I don't feel good
about who I am because think about how
much pain or upset or frustration you
must feel for it to spew out to others
like I remember I had this like like
horribly shitty time in my life when
um long story short my I went to
Pepperdine paid for my own school and my
mom's my mom's family had money and her
dad was like I'll loan you not give it
loan you with interest
to help pay for your school because I
only got like half of it through
scholarship so it was like sixteen
thousand dollars a year with interest
so generous
um anyway all right grandpa
um anyway he offered to like pay and
then my second year he got a little like
senile and like three weeks before
school was supposed to start he's like
I'm not paying for it anymore oh my God
I had to withdraw and so I went in this
and I went to Community College to keep
up with my units but like [__] me like I
was so like you know like what am I
doing where am I going you know just
like life and upheaval and I was like 19
and it was like the darkest shittiest
time in my life
and I feel like that's where those
people have to be like where they don't
even know what they're doing they don't
even know who they are they're like in
this deep then even then I don't think I
would leave a comment because I just
feel so bad about like hurting someone
even though I was hurting do you know
what I mean I sound like I have it in me
but I think that whenever I think of
like where would they have to be in
their life that's where like yeah and
back to your question which maybe this
is what you were angling for because
it's what I would want to know is like
what is this doing to us what do we do
and this is kind of it's for everyone
who exists online like do you have
advice on how to cope with it
constant influx of negativity but then
positivity and also I love doing this
because it's how I express myself and
it's how I connect to others and relate
to others and
I know it's it's hard best advice I mean
I'll speak personally like as a Creator
and then I'll talk more like therapisty
um but as a Creator I think the best
thing I've done is create safe spaces
which it sounds bad to say this but like
a paywall like I'm on patreon a lot and
that has like saved me because for
people to put money up they're not
they're not gonna [__] talk you like
I've never gotten hate from anybody on
patreon those are my people that's my
community it's like a safe space so
that's great and I've always loved that
um if our co-hosts were here she would
interject that in covid I had a patreon
and I only charged one dollar that's
fine and it was literally she would
always make fun of me like that's your
self-worth which is funny but my
reasoning was
just I just want people to like put a
credit card down and have so that it's
safe they have some skin in the game
yeah it takes a lot to get a credit card
you also can't be like 12 years old yeah
okay Mom I want the debit card yeah you
can't so it's a little safety like a
dollar five dollars just to yeah entry
that say that makes it better
um but also limiting what you read like
I mean I there's two veins I've seen
happen
so I was uh on the caller daddy podcast
and Alex has like
gets the she just turns off all her
comments I don't know if you've noticed
like on all our Instagram stuff because
you don't have to and Taylor Swift does
the same I'm not saying that I'm doing
but I'm just saying that like you don't
have to allow people to
no one says we have to
or you just let it ride and you don't
read anything
which is more what I do just let things
ride you know I also like on YouTube you
could hold words and stuff so that
because I don't want anybody in my
community to be told just go kill
yourself you know yeah because it
doesn't mean it's not always just
towards me it can be amongst themselves
where they like fight yeah and I'm like
don't fight on my behalf and don't you
know that must be a different kind of
pressure to to be a therapist publicly
and online like is there weird beef in
the therapy Community I mean not amongst
therapists as far as I know it is a
weird because therapy is like an art
which I know people probably wouldn't
agree or think of it that way but I
would absolutely everything is an art
it was we're creating something and as a
therapist you have to like figure out
where you're you're patient is you have
to meet them there and then you have to
help guide them out to a better place
right so like every person is a little
different the questions you're going to
ask is a little different and you're
trying to work with them so they feel
comfortable right so it's like this
weird dance that you do and so of course
not everybody's gonna like me first of
all I don't have the experience that a
lot of people are going to want like I
don't maybe don't look the way people
want me to look like I remember I posted
a video of me getting a tattoo and
people like therapists don't have
tattoos I was like then don't see one
who does you know like you want a
concept I know oh my God so people have
opinions about everything but yeah they
have a lot of judgments around like what
well I would have done this I'm like
good [__] go to school and get your
license then you know like good for you
yeah I don't know so the feedback is
hard but I just limit my my digestion of
it and then as a therapist I've always
told my patients like
pay attention to who you follow and what
you follow online like what you allow
yourself to read and if you feel worse
after don't follow those people and if
they're friends and you're like oh
they're gonna be offended then mute them
like and like meet with love it's not
because we don't like them it's like I
always tell people it's not about them
it's actually about me it's like I can't
watch your content or see you doing
these things and not feel like feel
upset either about my life my
relationships where I'm at what I'm
doing so I'm not gonna
watch it like it anything I saw this
thing recently where I think it was
actually the founder of liquid death was
on a podcast and he talked about like
which is very everyone knows this but
it's like if you make a product or you
are a thing or a podcast or whatever and
people love it if people love it there
will also be people who hate it and
there's no escaping it and that I find
to be very freeing it all like there's
so many things like this like in
marketing they say or advertising
there's like this famous saying I can't
tell you
um how to have success but I can tell
you how to fail try to please everyone
oh 100 you can't please everyone and so
I have found solace in these concepts of
like great I'm people are gonna hate me
no matter what so I'm just gonna like be
so so true to who I am so that the right
people come
and the wrong people will still come but
I will at least know that I am myself I
don't know does that resonate or help
you I'm curious yeah but it's a little
bit
um harder for me to get there because
I'm definitely codependent and I've
spent my whole life
chasing the affection of my mom or
validation or praise or and I love you
or a good job so like I find that I seek
that also and like other people a lot so
like when I put something out and people
are like that's you're ignorant and
you're dumb and you're a dumb gold
digger it's like
wow I couldn't please Jack from Missouri
like I must like be really a terrible
person this isn't the beginning but now
I'm finally getting to the place of
believing that yeah and you said I had I
don't know if this is this resonates
with you guys but recently I had like
this Epiphany where I I'm like a soft
person definitely a people pleaser and
that's like my own therapeutic work this
therapist should be in therapy
you know we don't we can't fix ourselves
it's not like giving myself a haircut
um that'd be awesome if I could but I
can't
um anyway there are people that do and I
see them I'm like how I know they do the
ponytail I can't even wax my own
eyebrows that's a disaster you know like
I just pay the people to do the things
they know how to do I'm not that person
I tried giving myself bangs in college
and my mom wouldn't speak to me for six
months I gave myself a mullet I have an
unhealthy obsession with watching people
cut their hair on Tick Tock because you
know it's gonna be bad they like pull it
so straight and I'm like oh honey
this is the length I want to I'm like
it's gonna bounce up it's not even dry
if that shit's wet it's probably about
you know you're like you just watch it
and wait
um but you were saying anyways yeah so
I'm definitely like a softer
people-pleasy type person yeah and I
realize being online it made me like
incredibly hard and I didn't like that
about myself and I can relate to that
because I liked that I was like soft and
I'm a Feeler and I can like sense things
and that I thought that made me hi Ani
[Laughter]
nice to meet you girl hey Annie
you're fine
are those gifts I mean kind of I throw
my stuff in here but I wanted you guys
to try these chips have you ever tried
oh yeah I eat those all the time chicken
waffles the the Buffalo one chicken are
you vegetarian no they're made with
chicken and then no judgment for
vegetarian
like judgment but I'm like
they're made with it it's mostly it's
protein chips but with a little bit of
tapioca yeah yeah it's delicious
not right now but I will definitely
later you'd love a master because
they're just protein chips no I know
I've been wanting to try those Caroline
is obsessed with them but I'm not a
waffle it's so it's like the weirdest
it's probably just like sweetness will
this help you Whitney told me about that
I do love them wait I want it you were
saying that you're soft but it's made
you like I like thickened my skin made
me hard and I realized that I didn't
like that like I didn't like what being
online for 10 years had done to me like
because I was kind of like
I was more protective and I like
wouldn't read things and then if anybody
was even going to give me constructive
feedback I'd be like [__] you yeah
because I was just like I'm out I'm all
feedbacked up thanks got way too much
feedback and so it was like a couple
months ago I was like you know what I'm
gonna let myself like just be and if I
want to cry about something I'm gonna
cry about if I want to feel I'm gonna
feel
um still working at it because it feels
to be vulnerable online I hate because I
don't like that people can get at me you
know but um but I realized I didn't want
to lose that part of myself it wasn't
worth it let me relate to that yeah I
think of all the things I I can relate
to that the most because I I do think
I'm a softy and
um just having done this for so long you
cannot help but put your you'd be
prickly and your you know your defense
is up okay even to people who are being
perfectly nice to you you're always like
oh like what is that what are you saying
what do they want you what do you want
yeah well it's hard to with like are we
talking about comments yeah because you
just don't know like who
now comment is so there's so little
information behind the person who's
giving you the comments you know
especially on YouTube it's like you
can't really like if you click on them
you don't get it's not like there's like
a bio that really tells you much about
them for the most part it's like so it's
like I don't even know what you're
coming from a week yeah but we were
asking Katie earlier like what happens
like what is the long-term effects of
being exposed to
um the public in this way and in a very
like parasocial way yeah where people
aren't attacking your craft they're
attacking you yeah yeah
that was making that realization as to
like how unusual it is
that the amount of access we have to
random videos of uh mass shooting news
and comments of people saying they hate
you that was a big driving force and why
I started taking Lexapro because I was
like wait I know for a fact that I have
not my humanness has not evolved to
handle this [__] yeah and so I'm just
I'm curious like being aware of that do
you have any tools or helpful thoughts
on like how to cope while we deal with
these things that were very much not
evolved to deal with yeah I mean there's
a ton of things we can do and you're
right like we shouldn't be disconnected
to
um
trauma right like shared trauma like
it's so easy I remember I forget when
this was it was like a few years ago
where like a girl was like drunk driving
with her little sister in the car and
they got in this horrible accident her
sister died and you're like watching she
was live streaming it oh and I was like
what the actual [__] is happening oh
like last week that guy was on Facebook
live when The Nepalese plane went down
and killed 72 people and he was like
look we're about to land and then boom I
see the flames and I'm like I did not
want to watch that video
um it was just on the news there wasn't
like a warning for anything I was like
oh I just saw someone just go up in
Flames yeah I've seen like life leave
people's bodies on the internet
I'm like I just saw your solely right
I'm like I'm not an EMT for a reason
it's too much I like your little
Wednesday Adam arms thank you yeah
um yeah how yeah that's weird anyway
yeah no you're fine
um but to that point like because we're
so it's so accessible like I don't want
to see life leave people's bodies like
um the best thing we can do is limit
exposure so I know it sucks to feel like
you're not informed but like sometimes
being informed just means like
traumatized maybe I won't be informed so
there's that and then also weird things
you can do that like reset your nervous
system so you know you can feel like
tingles in your fingers when you're like
stressed or like tense or like your
breathing is shallow like
stomp your feet a little shake your
hands out it like triggers your nervous
system to release that pent up energy
because the way our bodies are like not
to get too nerdy but the way that
they're built is our nervous system is
made to look in our environment for
threat and then if it sees a threat it's
like okay do I fight flight you know
freeze font like what do I do how do I
manage this but if we're threatened and
there's no way we can't do anything with
it this threat is like
our world like what then we freeze and
all that energy just courses through
which feels like anxiety yeah it can
feel like
that like I can't catch my breath
you know I don't know how to turn my
flicking watch off I don't understand my
Apple watch either what is it there's
one button I hate it
mine goes off all it'd be like and then
like another thing shows up I'm like
that's not what oh now I need a passcode
has been on my [__] wrist the whole
time okay my passcode okay I don't know
what my password is Carlos fix it mine
buzz me at five in the morning it's like
you need to get up I was like you need
to shut the [__] up you need to go back
to analog baby I love your watch thank
you the thing about all of this like
that were these like you know that we
haven't gotten the upgrade yet from our
like prehistoric days when we were
cavemen is so funny because of all I
know that it's like when you're having
like social anxiety is from when you
were like because if you got
excommunicated your life was in danger
right if you got this communicated from
your tribe back in the day but it's just
funny that you can go into fight or
flight if someone like calls you a fat
[__] online when are we gonna I'm ready
for the upgrade right they're gonna
excommunicate me I can't be I'm about to
die I'm about to freeze in the snow
because I have no body weight
no one to help me forage I'm like come
on I'm a fat [__] don't you want to hug
me in the snow
I think it is so funny like perceived
threats like even in the form of words
I'm like this is really gonna dictate my
day I'm just gonna be like sweating in a
corner at home like caring so much it's
really quite pathetic if I were to just
zoom out a bit and be like oh look at
kalila over there well also like as a
comedian like I started my first sort of
exposure to an audience was with Opie
and Anthony the like oof shock jock yeah
so my all my first fans were people that
were just like thought that the way to
show love was to just completely roast
you oh my God look at those bug bites I
was always about how small I was like
never and then I would be
self-deprecating and then they would do
it back it was just like crazy I'm like
oh my God and then I gained weight and
now they're bigger
jokes on you sorry
I have a question is it possible
that a person maybe me I'm exploring
this theory is it possible that I could
have maybe been living the past
10 15 years in a state of PTSD
yes like in freeze or in I don't know
well she thinks she's a dog tell her
about Jacob
Annie don't go harder we talked we went
over her diaper use
she was like we're going this is too
much too fast I'm just curious that was
episode one too by the way of our diaper
or Esther as a dog I think I think dog
was like 10th episode
I when I was little I wanted to be a dog
and I mean call me Jacob and I only ate
out of bowls off the floor it was
because I met a dog named Jacob who I
was really drawn to and wanted to become
him did you have a chat and you guys
shook hands and stuff and he was like
nice to meet you
how long did that last just like
seriously oh not that long
one you posted that is just like you're
obviously like in charge
everyone's like around you was that the
Jake picture but it's really just a
picture of Esther with other classmates
near her we was at the Jacob era no that
was probably a little after Jacob I'm
thinking I can't tell I could have been
like kindergarten or tenth grade yeah
just with the way you have aged but like
I I don't this was just a random theory
that popped up in my head because I
basically like
I am trying to really figure [__] out
and like upgrade my brain software and
I'm like oh is getting dumped in high
school was that did that like make me
have really severe anxious attachment
that then like I've had for the last 15
years I mean it could have triggered it
I think it's probably because your
parents were emotionally neglectful
without realizing it and like the biting
people don't talk about this enough but
because they're like oh kids do that no
children who are neglected do that oh my
God it's not like there's a direct
correlation but whenever I hear someone
bit as a child it's abuse is like the
red flag like because there's things as
a therapist that you're like oh that's a
little red flag like if a child
start starts wetting the bed again after
they were potty trained
in other ways
catch the goop yeah yeah yeah cotton
gusset do you guys mind if I just really
quickly I know she's at work but um if I
just call my mom and ask her about can I
fill her in while you're calling on some
things sure Esther just Road starred uh
and made a movie about this breakup in
high school she's obsessed let's just be
clear I'm 34.
foreign
like that but she is
where is this [__]
she's neglecting you yeah triggered he
had a cage asked her how to like
breastfeed thing yeah
you know nipples are hard to find a
little on the pink side but one of her
childhood members is like white
knuckling the the like child gate like
not in memory but I I just my parents
have told me that when they would wake
up in the morning I would be asleep
hanging onto the gate oh what was the
game that they bring it up my parents
are like we don't remember that
we don't go there I'm like oh okay
nope I think it's neglect yeah I think
and I do think I only bit someone once
that's why I want to get that's the tea
from my mom and I just remember she's
just the way she says that she was like
really embarrassed and then it never
happened again because she she was
humiliated is that why
well it didn't get you what you were
wanting probably yeah like children act
out in the only ways they can so a lot
of it's like relationally like like the
biting or like picking fights or being
the perfect kid like I was that I was
like trying to be like if I'm the best
then everybody will like me and it will
all be good and like that's super toxic
too you know so like it's funny to think
that the kid that's getting like
straight A's is just as like messed up
as a kid who's like the class clown yeah
that is crazy it's just different way
it's like coping or just dealing with
like what tools do we have is there a
way to not get [__] up by our parents
like is there like a way yeah you're
like are we gonna be pretty are we gonna
be terrible parents or impart trauma in
our kids as well like I mean possibly
you know like probably I think we all
pass on things whether we want to or not
and like behaviorally you can't pass on
like symptoms of trauma because of the
way you react to the world right so I'm
gonna quickly interrupt if she's calling
back Mom yeah hi I'm recording the
podcast did I bite my girlfriend
uh yeah YouTube
I but what happened
um
it was at uh
play group of mom attached clay group
and
um a little kid I guess came down the
slide and he wanted to go up and you get
him in the cheek oh my God the chick was
that during my Jacob era
um oh yeah it must have been perfect
yeah I love how she just answers this
what uh what else was I doing in the
Jacob era
um while you were biting everyone except
me
anything else uh no that's all I
remember okay love you bye I love you
just randomly asking about your mom's so
nice to be like no I think this she is
the real commuting genius somehow that's
what I'm slowly realizing your dad too
they're both so funny this weekend Dave
my fiance we were we were in New York
and we were talking about September 11th
and Dave was telling my mom how
he like he was he watched The Towers
fall from his rooftop and my mom like he
was he told us like you know his New
York 911 tale and my mom he says like we
watched it fall my mom goes well I hope
you covered your mouth
because of the bad air I'm like I don't
think he did like what the [__] that's a
strange response mom yeah you're like
wow that must have been hard it's a
better answer I hope you covered your
mouth sorry we interrupted no you're
fine but like the biting and stuff it's
interesting about your mom I wonder if
she was the one that you wanted the
attention from the most
I'm looking at ukulele did she use a
spray bottle I like curb the habit or a
thing with like a can with pennies in it
yeah
um that is so interesting Esther I wish
I knew you at this age because I had a
pet noodle remember I I didn't go
through a Jacob era but
um I went through a time where I felt so
lonely as a child that I tied a string
to a chow mein noodle and I named him
Jerry and he followed me everywhere like
I would take him on Plane Rides because
I would do swim meets and Rod I was just
gonna say one day my sister had enough
and she just smushed Jerry she was like
enough boom it was just a smash Noodle
and then it could not be Tethered to a
rope anymore or a string did you get
another noodle or were you uh no I was
heartbroken Jerry and then I and then as
an adult I was gifted not gifted I um
rescued
um a boa like a and then I named him
Jerry in honor of my noodle Jerry I
imagine like a feather boa and uh any
real pets
I hadn't met your dogs I would be like I
bet this [__] just has stuffed animals
I am like so attracted to you after the
noodle story uh and before it
you say I did it these are the most
comfortable things I've ever had in my
life get them everybody children get
them
um I she's had them forever I really
relate to that and I also remember in
middle school I asked the I like was
wondering if you could have a sperm as
pets I like after that I would ask guys
like no the sperm's too it's bigger than
you after
listen you're not going to be able to
keep it under control like I really
wanted a guy to give me like his sperm
in a cup so I could like see them how
old are you middle school middle school
old or young no just I'm just surprised
that you were so interested in sperm
it's so mean but did you have the front
I feel like we've talked about this on
here but did you ever have the friend
that was like really really or were you
the girl that was like really obsessed
with puberty no it was never me no I had
a friend that was like that yeah I was
terrified who was just like all she
wanted was the teacher to give us like
extra lessons on puberty and growing
pubes and boobs and stuff like she was
just like couldn't get enough of it she
loved our bodies ourselves it was like
dog ear and everything oh my God
highlighted she did have lesbian moms
which I wonder if she was like just her
parents were like very oh probably
talking to her about a lot of stuff but
I had a lot of friends with us like was
like very confused as a kid or I guess
not confused I was a lot more I'm less
confused than other people
I Quaker School I recently came across
this term oh that's right I mean I did
not know that Katie you quite possibly
are amongst the most [__] upselling
girls and exists oh yeah I was just the
opener
wait till wait till you get to Annie
yeah yeah yeah this is our charcuterie
of all like I think we cover all the
kinds of trauma
um possible and we're like so not afraid
to share we just give it all that's our
gift but I like that though because it
normalizes the reactions because kids
are doing it whether they want to talk
about it or not yeah and we often do the
things like the noodle you know or or
like wanting to pretend that you're a
dog like people are embarrassed to talk
about it when you're older because
you're like what the hell yeah you know
no one wants to be like I'm totally
[__] up I mean now I guess people say
it as a joke but like in a real way of
like how do I what happened to me I know
it's so weird when you because I feel
like with myself I was always like I
took on internalize so much stuff and I
took on responsibility for everything
that happened to me my childhood always
and then I hit like
I think it was like around 32 or
something and then all of a sudden I got
so mad at everyone else I was like wait
a second this was you like not people
but like you know the adults in my life
and I was like what the [__] and then
now I've like now I I'm able to like
disassociate and look at it from like a
more
um like relaxed and forgiving like a
perspective of Grace for my parents and
for everyone where you can kind of see
where they were coming from but it's
like
been quite a roller coaster yeah and
anger's interesting because I went
through that phase too I was like Angry
all the time because I was like what the
[__] you know and like rage
um but something that I've learned is
like and I'm still not totally
comfortable with anger it usually comes
out that way like we're all like stuff
it down and then it's like raw
um is that it's just indicative of you
being hurt like it's just it's your
puffer fish you're sticking your spines
out like you said it's the spiny it's
that protection because you you're like
because you were upset yeah like what'd
you do why'd you do this to me why'd you
say that what the [__] was that I'm
lucky my parents are like do their own
work on themselves and stuff and they
definitely let me just scream at them a
lot that was really nice thanks guys
my bad no it's helpful when your parents
do their own their own work my mom is in
therapy too and my dad died when I was
like 24.
um but it's been really helpful that she
has her own Insight you know because I
should she'll come out of the blue and
she'll be like I'm so sorry
yeah that I didn't say that to you or
that I did this or that I didn't divorce
your dad early you know like all the
things that she's like I should have
done it differently yeah yeah it's so
impactful
to even hear your parents and even in my
mom there's a language barrier English
is not our first language so it's tough
for her like to kind of Express herself
as clearly or as fast as me
um but she sent my sister and I a tick
tock of a clip of Jane Fonda in an
interview saying
it's not that I didn't want to be a good
mom is that I didn't know how and that
was her way of saying hey this is what I
am saying but she said it like whatever
Jane Fonda says and by the way my mom
made us do Jane Fonda workout since I
was like six years old like she
um so I thought that was like I remember
looking at my sister and we both just
started crying like did you get the text
I'm like I did the Jane Fonda one I did
and I didn't know how to like react to
it because I was like really one of the
few times where there was like
acknowledgment of saying okay like I
might have [__] you up
um but it meant so much and if our
parents just knew how much it means tiny
little thing like these little my mom I
remember she sent me a card when I was
living when I first moved back to LA I
don't know how long it was like 2016 or
something and she sent me a card that
said like like love you my sweet girl
and just her calling me sweet because I
had such a like a story about myself
that I was bad
you know like that was like my core
belief was that I was bad and then I was
like oh just that like little thing I
just felt so lucky that she said that
and it's like it's something where I've
done a lot of work and like learned a
lot of tools to be able to do that on my
own without other people which is great
but it's such a nice little like cherry
on top to have the person who like gave
you the core wound give you that little
relief you know totally but I sorry I
was just what I love I love hearing
these things and like that's so cool
that just her saying that simple just
like a littlest thing it like affected
yeah and what I love too about your mom
sending you a Jane Fonda video is like
she didn't your mom didn't have to it's
really hard to put things in our own
words sometimes and I always think of
like my mom always buys greeting cards
and I'm like that's actually so
wonderful that people can express
themselves using other people's work and
art like I think that that's a an
underutilized tool in personal
relationships I'm like inspired to use
that yeah
will never go out of business my mom and
my stepdad they will spend two hours
looking for the right card for the right
words because they don't have it right
and then my mom will always just sign
mountains of love Mama but when I I read
someone else's words so closely it's
never just a card and I can never read
it in front of her around people when I
receive my birthday gift because I know
it's gonna bring out a lot of like Deep
Emotions so I'm always I always go to
the room after after everyone's left and
I read it and I always have like some
type of meltdown over it because I know
that they were on that aisle for two
hours looking for you know words that
match their feelings totally and I think
there was a time in my life where I
would like write that off and be like
these are someone else's words but now
I'm like no I know that that's a form of
expression like and it's yeah there's
there's real value there that I respect
and appreciate go Hallmark I love a
greeting card on poetry yeah I guess I I
kind of like I'm like thanks for the
card guys you know but it is it is nice
but the sweet girl would get you that
would be yeah that was good and then I
was able to really like shift my own
beliefs with myself it was it was really
cool yeah it's cool that you did that
like that inner child work stuff where
you like give it to yourself which I
know it sucks and it's never as good to
be like oh but I'm doing it for me
because but then when your mom gave you
that little bit it was just a little
like it's like a sweetener yeah because
that's really where you want to get it
from but from the therapeutic side it's
like we can't control that reliable yeah
and then they could wound you more yeah
when you're like yeah I came up with
like the best thing to do I don't know
if I've talked about on here before but
the best thing to do when I'm going
through a breakup and I'm really missing
that person I always text myself the
things that I would text them like I'll
go like I miss you I love you like Annie
I love that oh my God so yeah when I've
had to go no contact with people because
I know that's what's best for me but I
am
physically unable to at times because
I'm always like still I want to know
that they're thinking about me I I do
the same so I open up my notes and
everything I want to say to them I just
write in the notes right yeah and it
helps me just get it out there yeah I
miss you I love you I'm desperate for
you I can't stop thinking about you I
want to [__] hurt myself when like I
just everything is on there and it just
releases the pressure just a little bit
yeah I love that yeah it's a nice safe
space yeah buy a little like breakup
tricks it is to drive by their house and
make a movie about it for 30 years yeah
can we talk about that with Katie we can
yes
um is like I would I'd listen to like
love happy songs and I always think
about like talking to me yeah like my
high school breakup the one song we were
like did a dance to it in my dance
school whatever and it was lovely day by
Bill Withers and the lyrics like just
wouldn't look at you and and I would
like really be like these songs are
about me maybe
Alicia Keys No One I always like sing
that to myself when I was like a drunk
like bartender and go-go dancer in Santa
Fe New Mexico and I had like such bad
self-esteem I would like listen to that
song and just ride my motor scooter
around and just make it like I was
singing to myself yeah like you're a
badass yeah the hair the wind flowing
through your hair on my tits
missing nipple that I lost on a sidewalk
Annie and I really bonded over that and
early on like we both had nipple trauma
um her from a scooter and mine from a
skateboard yeah but just you know later
mine from a scooter nurse from a skater
right off I don't know why he was trying
to skate and suck my dick at the same
but Esther um let's um
let's let's walk down memory lane and
talk about let's drive by memory lane
well
hmm
yes so I think though like you're she's
Katie is pointing me in the direction
that like it's not about the breakup
it's about
how I was raised but it is true that I
have this like
this very traumatic High School breakup
right where like this person was my
whole world like I had a crush on him
for years before we started dating and
it like everything just worked out
really magically in this High School
relationship and then it you know it
ended abruptly and I was so just like in
shock and all the things that happen
when you get dumped and
um and then we essentially like never
spoke again and I always think that like
that's why I have this anxious
attachment where I'm like I think that
everyone's Gonna Leave me and then never
talk to me again and I think it's
because like oh I'm so annoying and like
unlovable and
then there's there's like a couple
things at play right like there's that
and yes I do drive by his house
sometimes but I also believe I really do
believe you park no I no sometimes like
sometimes if my dad's with us my dad
will be like he'll like pretend like
he's about to get out of the car and say
something like no no like it has to be
very incognitive oh you're my dad would
do that [__] too yeah
hold you like hostage but still
presently you still drive by I haven't
lately but I so on the other side of it
I do feel genuinely like part of it is a
Nostalgia thing like I I really do and
there's probably another mental illness
version but I love the past I love
revisiting the past I love learning
about just myself through my past like
I'm really I'm really committed to like
I feel like I'm donating my life to Art
and Science this year it's like I'm
gonna be honest and vulnerable like
let's figure this [__] out use me
instead of my organs like use my mind
like let's figure this out and
um so yes I do feel like there's a
Nostalgia there too so I that gives I'm
like giving myself a little credit there
where I'm like it's not just that I'm
obsessed with this guy and I know it's
not about the guy anyway Kyla that's
there you go I mean it's not it's not
that it's not about you it is cute I
mean first loves are interesting I
assume he's your first one yeah totally
because we've never experienced
something like that before and so when
we come out of our family especially if
there was emotional neglect so we didn't
really feel like our needs were being
met and we find a person who will and
you're like praise be to whoever I don't
have to go searching anymore I don't
feel so alone anymore I have this other
person and so that I call like the mom
or dad wound you like took this guy and
you put him in that wound and you were
like we're all good now yeah like all
that work Annie's doing you were like
I'm just gonna put this person in it to
fill it we that also makes so much sense
too because so when my parents would
very rarely go out and when they did
like my sister would just be the
babysitter and obviously she'd just be
alone in a room and like never interact
with me but there's one time where I had
a babysitter and to this day I remember
literally every minute of that night I
remember her name I remember like I had
one caramel apple and I was like I want
you to have it and like I remember I
wanted it so bad like I got it from
school and I just
I wanted her to have it I wanted to
watch her eat it and like she played
with me and like it was just this most
amazing night I've ever had and I still
think about it and it's like aligning up
with that it was like oh she was me she
was your needs she was mothering you in
the way you need it did she end up being
allergic to apples and she died
if I can kill her no but it's really sad
I never would be on brand for our story
not hers no I literally never saw her
again it was like a one a one and done
yet yeah oh it was your one night stand
yeah your emotional
oh my God that makes so much sense but
he was yeah so he was around for much
longer more than one night so imagine
the power of that and then the fact that
it was taken from you the reactive
attachment type thing always stems from
attachment is our first year of life so
like yes it can change and we can work
on it we can heal to become to have
secure attachment but your attachments
formed from birth to one year oh [__]
that's early yeah wait how is it even
possible it's like everything gets so
because when you cry they come to take
care of you when you are hungry they
feed you and you need to be changed like
think of like but I can't imagine any
world where I might like my mom was such
a caregiver like I know that she took
good care of me but emotionally is
different but even in the first year
they might have let you cry it out yeah
like ferberizing and stuff I'm not
saying that's wrong but for certain
children it doesn't do well like because
if you needed more if you were at the
thing you were crying yeah that's not
one year old that's that's but maybe but
if that's probably a reflection
holy [__] seven oh my God
oh my God I thought we were toddlers
oh my goodness once I was babysitting
this kid she's like a teenage girl
this is what I feel like I just did you
and I'm sorry I was babysitting this kid
in Santa Fe when I used to live there
and he was seven he was in first grade
and he had gone to the bathroom his mom
had left he and he went to the bathroom
he goes I'm done and I went okay cool
and he's like no I pooped and I go okay
and he goes I'm done you have to wipe me
and I'm like what
swipe you you're in [__] first grade
I didn't curse anything but I was like
what and I just want to know I must have
traumatized
teachers wiping his ass I'm like oh my
God where's your mom done to you all the
children that were besat by Annie need
to come forward
one no longer with us
yeah no I I am still friends with one of
the kids I babysat for she's so cute
she's doing she just got married isn't
it crazy the kids I used to babysit are
in college and I like see them on
Instagram sometimes I'm like oh my God I
forget how old I am wait I am so
unlocked right now I know this is I this
is good because I've been trying to put
these pieces together on my own like
recently and you're this is great but I
just am shocked by zero to one because I
mean it continues to form but that that
initial attachment and then to like what
is it seven when your subconscious stops
forming or whatever yeah and then I mean
and then all the way to 18 to when
you're like yeah your prefrontal cortex
is fully none of this is my
oh I did didn't I tell you that I did
like rebirthing stuff in my breath work
thing I went to college and did a whole
breath work thing but I did we did like
a rebirthing thing in a in a hot spring
okay it was so cool but I realized like
all of these things from my birth like
these really like specific things that
happened when I was little and how much
they
have impacted my life so I was born
breech did I do this on did I talk about
this no a little bit okay about the
breach thing but you unbreached yourself
right in the river I flipped my ass
around my memory I went I'm just gonna
flip myself around I just decided like
this isn't a problem I just was like I'm
gonna just decide there's no problems
but why why was being Bri that was
affected I was in a yeah so I was so I
have a twin brother so my twin brother
was born and so I was with him in the
womb for nine months and then he was
gone and then for six minutes I was
being born I came up breach I ingested
the [__] juice is that the technology
yes the PJ and um
it so then I was in an incubator for 70
jnj so then I went from like being so
close with my brother and my being all
by yourself to being completely by
myself so and then being really like and
then I just realized there was a lot of
like
I had like held on to a lot of trauma
because my mom didn't want twins because
her mom was sick it was just like a like
to my mom it felt like a really bad time
to have twins and they would always tell
the story about in when they got the
ultrasound how my dad was so excited
about twins and my mom started crying
and so I internalized that and then my
my grandmother passed away my mom was
pregnant with me and my twin so she was
like really devastated and so I just
like took a lot of that on and then I
just didn't realize like how much of my
life I was apologizing for being born
you know yeah and really you can't take
up space you don't right to be here yeah
and I take up so much space so it's so
confused I think that's like the the
reaction yeah because you're like I'm
here yeah you know but part of you is
like still like it's you're worthy of it
I have like all this stuff in my jaw and
my neck too and every time I get work
done someone's always like that's
because like you haven't spoken Your
Truth or whatever but I'm I always think
of myself as always grab the throat a
lot I don't actually get strep throat oh
yeah I've one of my because I've been
practicing yoga for a long time and
breath Works off and they always say
like because I have trouble taking up
space yeah loud and they're like and I
get strep throat yeah yeah and they're
like that's because you're like not like
saying you're keeping like that trauma
in and it's poisoning your throat or
something yeah yeah you know something
amazing happened to me last week and I
think it healed me more than I thought
anything could in a split second and I
all three of us suffer from pretty bad
TMJ mine is because when I'm nervous I
just clench my I don't grind my teeth at
night but I kind of do this and so I had
to go to an orthodontist because I've
done just about everything I've gotten
Botox to my master and still that's such
a temporary relief and I'm like look I
so I was like okay let me try an
orthodontist and she came in very like
you know like everyone was like you
gotta see Dr Yamada Dr Yamada is the
lady so I'm gonna go see Dr Yamada he's
so excited about her braces yeah that
would be so cute to have a braces but
basically basically she said these are
crowded and the other is the top are
spacing and what your teeth try to do is
they try to make a perfect okay latch so
that causes a lot of just you know yeah
attention stuff but that wasn't what
changed my life they take a whole like
x-ray right and they show you your teeth
but what I saw was the end of my life as
a skeleton because all I just saw was my
cranium my jaw I saw myself as a
skeleton basically they said give you
those images I'll send you the picture
oh my God he's gonna jerk off to it oh
for the show okay I know I was like oh
they have like a pre-arranged you got a
little jealous
but in that moment I was like that's how
it ends that's what I'm gonna look like
at the very end for me none of this
matters you think now I give a [__]
about a [__] comment I've seen How It
Ends that's what the [__] I look like at
the end it's all good life is okay
finally you don't have Diet anymore
Annie my jawline is incredible I'm like
oh my God but it was in that moment
where I was like oh none of this [__]
matters like or at least not the small
stuff seeing your your skeletons
yeah I had a moment of like oh that's it
that's me at the end of life and [__] it
[__] it all I'm just gonna do me and
live in the way that I feel is most
authentic to myself I feel like
hallucinogen's always like I always have
this sort of like moment and
hallucinogens where I'll die and
uh everything is released and you're
like oh everything happened exactly the
way was supposed to happen
all of these worries were nonsense and I
mean I can't like obviously say that's
exactly what happens because I didn't
actually die but I feel like that's what
happens when you die what are your
thoughts about like um like ketamine
assisted therapy or hallucinogens to
sort of like Aid in
um someone's um um therapy I think it's
great I'm excited to hear more I mean
this research is ongoing so I can't say
that I'm like totally abreast at like
what they're finding out day and day but
I know that um like Maps is a great
resource if you want to go to map
they're the ones doing most of the
research yeah and
I think that it doesn't to me it doesn't
logically make any sense for us to
create medications in a lab with
pharmaceutical companies go through this
FDA approval and be like that's okay but
this grows in the ground [__] that [__]
right and I'm not saying like yeah but
like yeah you know it doesn't make any
sense why we wouldn't do research in
that phase either and like it all should
be available
[Music]
it changed my [__] life I do a raver
style though I'm like yeah
oh by the way Katie we have this thing
called banana break and it's really just
as a oh we didn't even tell her until we
just handed her a banana you're in a
really deep part too you're like I saw
my own death and there's just a guy
squatting well he's just like whatever
we have this thing called a banana break
where it just breaks the tension in the
room and we do a re-up on potassium I
don't think we've ever talked it right
to be honest yeah but we don't have to
eat the banana if you don't if you don't
um it is interesting it's just like you
know it's our little eating disorder
Galore was one some days were full some
days we're not but the realization they
try to give us a cupcake once that was
the end of our [__] life we almost
had to cancel the show people were
really upset that we were handed
cupcakes and we didn't eat the cupcake
because I had just eaten a full meal it
was 11 in the morning I just done Hot
Yoga it was like Harlow and I had a
special dessert plan
I didn't want to that day but everyone
was like you la Eating Disorders I was
like oh my God like when I eat sugar my
stomach hurts a little you know if I eat
like a cupcake but whatever yeah
but it's not in front of you [__]
yeah I guess it's completely normal I
would have taken a bite and it would
have been chill but I'm not chill or
normal what if you started eating it out
aggressive cupcaking so wait what did
you want what was the favorite
um when I did ketamine afterwards the
realization was that oh I've been my
mom's Workhorse my whole life it only
makes sense that I needed to use horse
tranquilizer yes I was just to get
through a lot of the stuff that was
happening drank my ass I'm a [__]
horse like if we have Whitney on she'll
start riding you
she'll start feeding you apples
oh my God I'd love to be brushed by
Whitney that actually sounds like a
really brushing yeah well when I was I
was a diagnosed tactile defensive when I
was little and they took me to an
occupational therapist who would who are
touching a little bit yeah she would do
like this like vibrating fuzzy thing on
me that looks like a car buffer and then
she gave my mom like that surgical like
scrub brush that doctors use and she
would have to scrub me my ex-boyfriend
was always like oh what's wrong with our
daughter I wish I'd scrub her let's
scrub her
yes that makes sense scrubber did it
help it did help it was so uncomfortable
and it was like my least favorite thing
on earth it was like so gross to me why
was it you hated touch so much I just
didn't I mean I'm probably gonna I
always say I'm like the doctor probably
fingered me on the way out the amount of
inappropriate men fingering in my life I
came out feet first I bet you're just
like pop it in and pulled me out
a little too dark and like fingered my
mom and
figure your body oh my God came out
breach so it went up the app
security my mom said I came ass first
that's a really cute way to enter the
world Annie that's I'm gonna go out too
I'm almost like if you're born breach
should you just not tell the kid because
it's like why should she have to it
would be in my life it would be in me
well there is really yeah you hold on to
trauma your whole body the body keeps
score I know halfway through I do not
like it it's really like a very hard
maybe my neck is fake
no but there is a lot too if uh the way
that we're born first of all how we
enter the world is very important hence
why people do water births and things
like that I don't know if that's you
know I don't know if there's research to
show like it's less traumatizing it
probably is but there is a lot of
research about like being incube in an
incubator and stuff oh really or if you
have lots of surgeries like my brother
was born with a cleft lip and palate and
I think being in and out of surgeries
when he was little so much was like
super traumatizing to him yeah I don't
know if he's you know that's his own
business but like there's a lot of
research about children because you
don't get touch yeah which is probably
why you didn't like it because there was
that period where you really needed the
you know where they have babies I put
them on their chest yeah the skin that's
really important yeah my mom said that I
would only I didn't like being hugged
but I loved cuddling with my brother
because that's what you were used to oh
man call me back
they're coming to surprise me I'm so
excited my brother and my sister-in-law
my nieces I always surprise them because
my schedule's so crazy I don't have to
cancel on them so I always like pop out
of boxes and do stuff like that and like
or like the trunk I always pop out no I
don't
they're gonna like start taking like
psychology classes like was Auntie
really like how bipolar was on dude
popping out of boxes everywhere
always like in their closet I did scare
the [__] out of my ones because I it was
after kova the first time we saw them I
was like okay I don't want to like scare
them too much in this box so we put like
a box in the driveway so I put on my
leopard print jacket because they know
me as having a leopard jacket but my
niece didn't think Auntie has a leopard
print jacket she thought a leopard is
attacking me and she had like went into
full fight or flight like her face in
the picture she's like like so scared
when I popped out and she came to it
right away but it was so funny it was so
funny but they're coming to see me and
so they don't know that I know and
they're gonna surprise me oh oh that is
so cool you think they're gonna pop out
of the box I think they will I think
there will be a box involved
I love this family theme it is it's
really good I literally have a policy in
my life no surprises oh we'd stop
talking one surprise I love like the
extreme differences of our personality
like flash mob no flashback surprise and
it looks like so I want my boyfriend to
give me a flash mob for my proposal
that's a surprise flash mob do you have
where does one start the Journey of
repairing themselves if if it's like
this zero to one emotional neglect
because I'm like I it almost I'm like
irked by that because I just it's I
don't understand it like I can
understand that I got dumped and that
[__] me up I can understand that I was
alone in my room and I was bored I do
not understand ages zero to one I mean I
recently read I I'm not done with the
book yet but I I
um NPR did a segment about the book
attached and I know even though like I
remember what it looks like on the cover
right and it talks about just the like
the four attachment Styles but he does
talk about that very important age of
zero to one like if you were just made
you know um
if you were forced to cry it out versus
you know coddled during that moment yeah
what was that study they had with the it
was with like monkeys right and then
they have like a fake
yeah the good enough mother yeah that's
like I did a bunch of videos about like
[__] that happened in the past we
couldn't do those studies anymore yeah
because like animal rights because man
that breaks your heart to see those
little baby monkeys I know I just like
get it out of my head I wish I didn't
read it but um but yeah that's pretty
much kind of what it is is that even if
like your mom was is bad I don't mean
this is like a put down to her but she
was like the wire the wire mom the wire
monkey you didn't get the real mom that
you needed the like warm cuddling like
you didn't get the mom that was like
just take a nap and relax sweetheart
like it was like you know because like
okay there's the thing is in my case
there's so many opposing confusing
things like I was breastfed until I was
three and a half neither of my parents
worked the first seven somebody called
that sexual abuse
the first seven years of my life both
parents were always home they never left
to go to work so like that's where I I
get even more confused well okay so
couple things so we'll talk about like
what what's your first step like to move
out of this and it sounds like Annie's
kind of done some of this stuff already
so she's doing good um but the so when
it comes to parents being around it's
not just them being around the thing
about emotional neglect I think is so
hard for people to like tangibly grasp
is that
them being there feeding you putting a
roof over your head probably I mean we
need that those are all like Maslow's
hierarchy of needs you need those basic
needs to be met but the as you get up to
the peak of those needs some of them for
you were probably like to feel heard and
understood or soothed in a certain way
and like there was none of that so you
probably didn't get the like let me play
with her hair and tell her how much I
love her and let me tell her about my
day or would it be if I drink out of
this bowl she will if we literally
because I also always say I wasn't
raised I was watched yeah like I they
knew where I was I was safe but no one
and no one interacted with you yes and I
probably wanted that more than anything
yes and I would even ask questions and
they would say I don't know like I would
be like where do babies come from I
don't know is Michael Jackson a man or a
woman I don't know like no one answered
never ask those questions together
that's a bad answer
oh so you went through that whole phase
where kids asking no one would answer
you they say I don't know
breath work baby you know um you gotta
do breath work what helped for Bobby a
lot was when he went to this um one week
trauma-intensive and Arizona and
um they make you go to build a bear and
they make you record something that kind
of makes makes you feel like this bear
is your the child the wounded child and
so you carry this bear around and it's
still at his house and anytime he feels
like like his inner child is like
suffering or he can like go to that bear
and he can give that bear what the bear
never had and it's very healing for him
does that make sense where it's totally
yeah it's called inner child work so
that's really where the first I mean
it's a big First Step but that's really
what you could do like I love the
Build-A-Bear yeah
um there I forget the name of the book
but there's a book that I've used and I
put together an inner child Workshop a
few months ago
um but right in your dominant hand like
the one that you write inside
left-handed as adult you to little you
and then right back in your non-dominant
hand from a little Journal can be
[__] wild I have definitely been
answered in my journaling I've never
tried to read the old ones you're like
yeah you know sometimes you see into
parts of yourself that maybe you can't
it might not feel safe enough to think
about it on the regular or it also just
might not be accessible all the time I
think that could be helpful for you I
feel that in my chest because it's like
you're writing with your left hand and
it's not as stable it does look like a
kid yeah it's so sweet and then you get
to ask for what you wanted like what did
you wish your mom and dad did answered
your questions rubbed your back played
with your hair yeah anything right write
down some of the things and then that's
how I follow Hawaii about you we should
play one game
Dino you missed out that day we went to
the Mormon Temple Annie and we did we
did a whole photo shoot I always had my
ass out at the Mormon Temple yeah
I think I was I don't remember watching
the news yeah
um I also do want to clarify because
first of all I'm like unlocking so much
and I'm really really excited about it I
want to clarify though I know that my
parents did their best and I do not hold
any of this against them and like I know
that my mom was a very and I've always
it's almost like just reaffirming things
I've always known but you are a
therapist and you say them so clearly
and like I feel so seen and heard by
this conversation but I know that like I
know that my parents did a good job and
the best they did it was the best they
could yeah yeah one parents it's like
having a certain set of tools that
you're working with they but they
weren't always the ones you needed yeah
but also like I always think about this
too like just generationally like we're
evolving so much because of the internet
and so much information can come out but
it was like they had like so many
different parenting tools right they had
like Dr Spock was like what that was
like what the 70s or 60s I think the
early 70s yeah yeah and then like so all
the philosophies like I was really
lactose intolerant and my parents didn't
realize so they would like feed me all
this milk and then I had all these
[__] problems and constipation and
stuff which was like really traumatic as
a kid but they didn't it just wasn't
like lactose intolerance wasn't like a
thing people why would they know yeah
yeah so I can't be like mad at them
they're working they're trying to read
and they're told yeah they're like
calcium is good for kids you know yeah
they're being marketed to drink more eat
more and you're like well but it's like
we're in a really cool position that if
we do decide to have kids we do have
like a lot of we have learned a lot
we've evolved a lot totally and two
things can exist I think this is the
struggle especially with stuff like that
and just things in our life where we can
know our parents did their best best or
that they loved us and we can also
acknowledge that it wasn't the way that
I needed it or that was still hurtful
and those things can exist at the same
time for some reason we feel like it's
one or the other but like that's life
like people will people think
differently like people are able to able
to give you different things and then
this is maybe what like this is your
expectation this is what they're able to
give and we have to try to like grieve
that difference and right and be like
okay that's what you can offer
I'm okay with that yeah you know and
then I get to process what that felt
like like okay I can still be upset my
parents did the best they could I know
they loved me but I also recognize it
like I needed to be heard more I needed
to feel seen more
and then you can like I need it to rest
more and like hear yourself more like
whatever it is like I always feel like
whatever I'm not getting from a
relationship with someone else I do when
I really like break it down and think of
a Spam great oh
never mind spammed him down but um
um he's eating spam
but like I whatever it is that I'm like
lacking in a relationship is really
something I just need to give myself
like it has to come from me anyway for
to really matter so it's like if I'm
pissed that someone
isn't listening to me or whatever I just
have to like sit and really like be with
myself and listen to myself I like to
think of stuff I'm doing a lot I just
came back from an Ayahuasca Retreat so I
didn't tell you guys that oh that's
right
no we can't say out out oh okay yeah I
think I might have heard I think you
said it outside the Universe
I like to when I think about my mom or
where I'm at at least in my life I like
to think about it as oh I bore witness
to her Evolution and she went from
scared young mom not giving me anything
I need to being an amazing person today
and really you know not perfect and you
know but I kind of it's kind of cool I
feel honored that I got to see this
person evolve and she is my mother she's
this 3D thing she's just not mom she is
this human being that has lived a very
complex life and to see her now in her
60s being a com like just someone I
can't recognize my young self could
never recognize is really soothing for
me yeah your mom's really cool it's so
nice like going to that Fourth of July
party at your house and your mom's just
there like so like I know she's so down
she's like a fan of yours she she is and
she's like you know just completely
desperate fans I feel like all of our
parents are like fans of us yeah yeah
like they really pay attention to what
we're doing and I feel so good about my
relationship with my family right now
like I just feel especially because
there's been more space in the last year
I feel like it's just I feel really good
about it yeah and you talking about your
mom I'm like I really almost just
started crying like thinking about
what our moms have gone through and how
their
I don't know I just in general I think
our culture is hard on motherhood it's
very difficult and like I think about my
mom
and I'm like she was pregnant at 21 not
with me but with my sister but pregnant
at 21 nine months pregnant was being
cheated on [__] nine months I'm like
imagine if you heard a girl if that was
a girlfriend of yours you'd be like I'll
murder him
right but like
that's I'm like oh my God I can't
believe my that makes me feel like my
mom is stronger than me like I'm like I
don't know and I just I don't know I've
I'm like holding love and space and
support and respect for that or
something also like her mom like
whatever her mom went through like she
had to handle the burden of that as well
it's like we're like carrying on like
all of the sort of Trauma from our I
don't want to say ancestral trauma
because they make fun generational
trauma yeah I make fun of Whitney for
saying that she said ancestral she says
well she said I don't know what she says
but I I made a joke on her thing where I
said if you say
whatever it doesn't matter but um uh you
know you do and it's like and it's just
even if it's just like learn Behavioral
or just like literally in our DNA when
we're born we're like taking on some of
that
uh that which are I wanted this is a
total like different departure from the
whole trauma thing but I recently
um learned this term I was listening to
my friend Shanti Sharon she has a new
podcast out but she talks about this
this word called compersion which is
like the opposite of jealousy and
um it's basically like the way she
explained it is like you go to the bath
you're in a bar with your your fiance
let's say Dave and you come back you go
to the bathroom you come back and you
see that there's this beautiful woman
hitting on him and you see instead of
being like Oh you recognize that you
know what he's
um he is setting up like proper
boundaries he's not like giving into the
attention but I know that he probably
does enjoy this moment and I'm happy for
him I do feel that yeah I really like
love I don't feel like I know I saw a
good thing yeah yeah I'm like in China I
already you know I'm gonna make shirts
that say I have a crush on Todd and sell
them
no but I do kind of I feel like I'm
leveling up to that place where I think
Annie and I we've talked about it where
it kind of feels good when someone hits
on your man and you're like oh this is
probably like feeding him in some way
even though he'll never say it and I
just kind of want to be happy for that
moment because it's not a threat to our
relationship it's just a fleeting thing
but it's because you're secure in it too
I think jealousy comes out of insecurity
right it doesn't come out of like I
really think my man or my girl is going
to cheat on me it's more like I don't
trust in our relationship right I'm not
secure in it and then you'll hear people
that are like well I just don't trust
the one the women it's like well it
takes two yeah
that's like a like a sad excuse yeah
trying to run away from or something
yeah the reality yeah Dave is like the I
feel like my current partner is my first
real secure attachment and it's like
whoa that was it uncomfortable at first
yeah I thought I mean I it was not
secure for the first few years because I
was still you know myself but it was
like through
repeated like
I don't know it being him being who he
said he was repeatedly I like just it
happened the consistency was like
healing for you yeah yeah I again with
the NPR attached
um the book attached there was this
thing he said that really spoke to me
which is you know it's kind of been put
in our head all these years like if you
can't love yourself you can't possibly
love another but he was like no you can
really learn to love yourself in a
relationship when you are with someone
who's secure and someone like for
instance like Dave Like You There is
almost like a lot of epiphanies you have
when you're with someone like who is
really healthy and or even good or bad
epiphanies like I think some bad
relationships have taught me a lot about
myself I've been like a single one has
taught me something yeah and you're like
what the hell was I thinking with that
or like why was that so triggered yeah
why did yeah look instead of like
blaming that person it's like why did I
allow myself to be treated like what was
I feeling in my own self-esteem where I
thought I deserved that treatment
rather than this is like a monster and
yeah and like why didn't I go on one
date and be like no yeah that way of
life is helpful be in many ways and I
like it because it takes you out of
victim mentality and it puts you in the
driver's seat of your own life I love
that and that's the important thing is
that but is that people want to blame
everybody else that's a really powerless
place to be yeah because then you're
like well I'm just a victim to what
everybody else decides to do so I have
no control that's like the worst a good
life no it's better to like be in
control and then you feel like well then
I can make changes then I'm empowered to
like improve my life doing whatever I
feel is going to make me feel like a
better version I have a friend in my
life who is that but not a not currently
at like pointing the gun at me but it's
like
people who
they're always the victim every life is
out to get them and screw life is always
screwing them over like what which is
part of why I'm inspired to uh I was
like I have to do it I'm like looking at
a gun it's actually being exposed to
that has helped me not want to blame
others because it's so easy to be like
it's everybody's fault but like I want
to be in the driver's seat do you have
advice on how to encourage others to get
in the driver's seat of their own life
or is me even asking that it's like you
can't do anything so just let it go I
mean mostly you can't do anything only
thing we can do is just lead by
demonstration so like you doing what
you're doing is enough like you it sucks
and it's I have to remind myself but we
can't control other people even when we
mean we want to do it with love like
this would be so much better for you if
you just stop blaming everybody or this
would be so much better for you if you
just wouldn't like lash out randomly at
people then you'd actually have friends
or you know what I mean like we can see
things unraveling but
we just have to do our thing if they ask
you can support good decisions like I
feel like oh hey how do you think I
handled that or whatever like you
handled it terribly like you can be
honest you know what I mean but that's
about it it's only if they ask and it
sucks I know yeah oh [__] this has been
a very
um healing episode I know this is like
the most energized I've ever felt after
a recording like I just feel like yeah I
have so much information and I feel
understood and yeah thank you good I
know you need that that feel heard and
understood part and good color you
picked a good color did you know what
the set looked like I looked it up yeah
this was a very good choice very good
choice it's a holy color well the
Catholics love purple that's the color
for Versace for the season eggplant
well Katie thank you so much Katie of
course and you mentioned that you have
workshops yeah books workshops I should
have brought stuff oh I have your books
traumatized oh yeah yeah good good yeah
and we can find you on Instagram and
Tick Tock YouTube Instagram yeah Katie
Morton
k-a-t-i-m-o-r-t-o-n and that's my
website too so people do all the
workshops just go to katimorton.com
thank you so much and I hope that you'll
come back right okay even Esther's like
maybe once a week for an hour
talk to me about my trauma the last time
we had Dr Drew on
um
and I he wanted to just he was just so
fatigued after listening to her oh I
forgot about that yeah Delilah he by the
way he's a doctor like he checks your
knee like we were like we're molested
you like check and see if your reflexes
are good he like has like a stethoscope
we were like they bested us as children
well he's both no I know he's that too I
know he's in my room yeah yeah I got you
on the system but we were like on the
edge of our seat like I'm like are you
done are you done okay but then what
happened to me like with me Annie and I
were in a fist off
he's coming back just fisted down the
lane is what we call it so this is these
episodes are always so just cathartic
for us and the last time Dr Drew like he
was like all right I'm done we were like
no don't leave mommy don't go now we're
doing it to her we're gonna do so you
guys thank you so much for listening and
thank you to Katie for all that she just
did for us and we will see you next week
with an all new episode
foreign
[Music]